Hallo Christina Stürmer
ich hätte seine Frau und ich wollten
mehr Pech hast du vor einigen Jahren ein
auch die gegen St
gleichzeitig seit zehn Jahren als
Musikvideo und West auf ja
auf Kritik er zählt sein werde
noch muskelbepackte durchtrainierte
Sportschau Motiv
deshalb ist Freiheitsstrafe
den Medien berichtet wird
Schubladendenken
glaubst du dass die Rede von uns kennen
würden nachdem Plech zugleich auch
Griff
Verantwortliche interessieren ich hoffe
du bringst guter Kommentar zu statt sich
herauszureden
Janina Jahr hatte ich mir jetzt nicht
gehört» daraus Rengers ich bin auch
kein einziges Team gingen nach Medien
geht eine
ich muss ehrlich gestehen den
muskelbepackten um Menschen in allen
Medien ist immer ehrlich sind nicht
aufgefallen wir wissen gar nicht so
musste bekannt das sind
der Minister der Sportler drinnen einem
Spurt um
es ist sehr recht sehr schön aus
Kuhmist noch keine Kinder drängen um
diese nicht zu muskelbepackten
aber
dass die Klimaanlage nicht mehr auf
keinen Fall dass alle Gamer am OHG
laufen wolle Scanner damals fuhren
davon sollen zeitnah einem Gerichtsort
oder sogar den Plätzen von Sumann der
erstens war 2003
Aben da man hat einige Zufälle in den
Zeitungen zu lesen Hamburg
von Netzwerken DM kein wirklich Tag und
Nacht
dort spielen teilnehmen
Extremisten den spielen Moment wo du
warst nicht anzusehen war
egal die extrem langen Kitzingen und
gehen dann halt
Werner Stump Prozent schlimme Dinge
gemacht haben
um Menschen gestorben sind und das hat
mich dazu bewegt um
entlastet nicht dass das irgendjemand
anders jetzt merkt dass er sehr gerne
wird das nicht machen
also ich will niemals alle Gamer in
einen Topf werfen aber damals Vater
damals so dass das Tier auf
wer Zeitung zu lesen oder einen
Fernsehen zu sehen war das hat mich
verlangen
extrem bewegt